.
GLAD IT IS FRIDAY.
>> Carley: ALWAYS CRYSTAL CLEAR,
MY FRIEND.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MEETING WITH
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS IN
FLORIDA, WHILE THERE SURVEYING
THE DEVASTATION, HE TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BLAME CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PUSH THE DEMOCRAT'S
GREEN AGENDA.
>> President Biden: THERE IS A
LOT GOING ON AND ONE THING THIS
HAS ENDED IS DISCUSSION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND IF WE SHOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Todd: THE PRESIDENT THIS THIS
INTERESTING HOT MIC MOMENT
TALKING TO THE MAYOR OF FORT
MYERS BEACH.
LISTEN.
[VIDEO PLAYING]
>> President Biden: [BLEEP] --
>> Todd: WHOA.
>> Carley: UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Todd: JOE CONCHA, AUTHOR OF
"COME ON, MAN," JOINS US NOW,
JOE, I ENDEAVOR TO READ THAT A
DIFFERENT DAY UNTIL THEY GIVE
THE READ TO CARLEY.
SERIOUS BUSINESS FOR A MOMENT,
CARE TO PROVIDE ALL THE PEOPLE
F'ING WITH A BIDEN, NORTH KOREA
AND OPEC JUST YESTERDAY.
>> Joe: NOTHING LIKE SOUNDING
LIKE CLINT EASTWOOD AND SAMUEL
L. JACKSON IN A DISASTER ZONE.
BY THE WAY, NOBODY MESS WITH
BIDEN?
I BELIEVE THE TALIBAN DID WHEN
THEY TOOK KABUL IN THE TIME IT
TOOK TO DELIVER PIZZA.
SAUDI ARABIA DID WITH RAISING
GAS PRICES HERE IN THIS COUNTRY
BY CUTTING BACK THEIR
PRODUCTION.
CHINA DOES ON A DAILY BASIS WITH
BIDEN AND NORTH KOREA LAUNCHING
MISSILES OVER JAPAN, THEY APPEAR
TO BE DOING THAT, AS WELL.
I GET A KICK OUT OF THE FACT HE
SAYS THIS STORM WAS ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE SHOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AS IF WE SPENT TRILLIONS
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
WOULD STOP A HURRICANE THAT
FORMED THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY
FROM HITTING THIS COUNTRY THAT
IT DID.
IT'S JUST AGAIN, NEVER LET A
CRISIS GO TO WASTE, ONE
POLITICIAN ONCE SAID, I THINK
ROB MCDANIEL.
SO MANY PEOPLE HURT AND BEING
EXPLOITED.
>> Carley: A FEW DAYS AGO HE
SAID HE WAS PUERTO RICAN
LITERALLY.
>> Joe: I LITERALLY AM.
>> Carley: GOT IT.
HE MADE THAT COMMENT WHEN HIS
SON IS UNDER FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION, I DON'T KNOW,
READING TOO MUCH INTO IT, MAYBE
NOT THE BEST TIME TO BE SAYING
NO ONE MESSES WITH MY FAMILY.
>> Joe: GREAT POINT.
WHEN THE GOP TAKES BACK THE
HOUSE AND THAT IS LOOKING LIKE
IT WILL HAPPEN, FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS LAUNCHING INVESTIGATION
INTO THAT LAPTOP AND TONY
BOBULINSKI WITH TUCKER AGAIN
THIS WEEK, TALKING ABOUT HIM
GETTING A CALL FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S BROTHER IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN FBI INTERVIEW, SO
MANY QUESTIONS THAT SO MANY IN
MEDIA ARE NOT PURSUING, I GUESS
IT IS UP TO EITHER THIS NETWORK
AND A FEW OTHER OUTLETSS IN
CONGRESS IN THE REPUBLICAN
VERSION TO TRY TO DRAW THIS OUT.
THE PRESIDENT COULD BE
COMPROMISED BY CHINA AND UKRAINE
AND WE DESERVE ANSWERS AS
VOTERS.
>> Todd: CARLEY TOOK THE SERIOUS
QUESTION, I'LL TAKE FASHION.
MEDIA IGNORING JILL BIDEN'S
HEELS AFTER BLASTING MELANIA
TRUMP FOR DOING THE SAME THING.
"NEW YORK TIMES" CLAIMS MELANIA
FINDS HERSELF ON THIN HEELS AND
FAILURE TO UNDERSTAND OPTICS AND
ACCUSING THE FORMER FIRST LADY
OF OFFERING UP FASHION MOMENT,
WE UP THE PICTURE OF JILL BIDEN
DOING THE EXACT SAME THING.
YOUR REACTION WHEN JILL BIDEN
DOES IT AND CRICKETS?
ARE THOSE FLATS?
>> Carley: SHE WAS WEARING
WEDGES, I BELIEVE.
>> Joe: YES, I HAVE A GO-GO
MACHINE AND I LOOKED BEFORE WE
DID THE SEGMENT AND TRIED TO
SEE, CAN I FIND "WASHINGTON
POST" OR VOGUE CRITICIZING
CURRENT FIRST LADY IN TERMS OF
FOOTWEAR AND YOU CAN'T FIND IT.
MELANIA WAS TREATED AS POORLY BY
THE MEDIA BY A MILE.
CHRISTMAS DECORATIONS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WERE RUTHLESSLY
MOCKED BY WASHINGTON POST AND
OTHER MEDIA OUTLETS, SHE IS A
LEGAL IMMIGRANT AND YET JIMMY
KIMMEL  MOCKED HER ACCENT AFTER
READING TO OTHER THAN WHICH AT
AN EASTER EVENT.
MELANIA SPEAKS FOUR LANGUAGES OR
FOUR MORE THAN KIMMEL.
NO SURPRISE DR. JILL BIDEN GETS
A PASS, DOUBLE STANDARD IS THE
RULE NOT THE EXCEPTION.
>> Carley: IT IS, INTERESTING
THE DIFFERENCE IN MEDIA
COVERAGE.
>> Todd: LIKE TO APOLOGIZE FOR
FAILING ON THE FASHION FRONT.
>> Carley: SHE WAS WEARING
HEEL